you're quite a good fighter you're
serious fighter yes now do you go to the
gym and and fight or do you fight in the
street so you like the kind of guy that
depends what happens okay no I know the
thing is you know I went on a show once
that kind of put me in a sphere that was
I mean just I'd walk down the street
people would walk up to me and punch me
in the head I know I work on that same
kind of show you're coded yeah no let's
explain what this meant you were on a
show called
EastEnders I was and EastEnders you
played on the show you played a tough
guy the Yard Man and a lot of people
really took that as if that's who you
really were you know the thing is when
you play a TV tough guy and I don't know
why I keep getting asked to play those
jobs but I do is that you'll be out and
someone will have two beers and that's
fine but when they've had the third they
see the tough guy if the TV in the
corner and they're like I can impress
this girl I'm gonna go and hit him and
they just do and it's really neat people
would just walk up to you in hitch yeah
they'd walk up to me and hit me or they
throw stones at me when I was in the
street or I'd be having dinner with my
parents and they were either hurling
insults or bread rolls okay yeah it was
a fun of all the things first of all
bread rolls I could I could handle that
oh I can handle an incoming bread roll
everyone gets hungry everything else
sounds sounds terrible so but what's
interesting is that because you were
getting picked on you decided to just
retreat and play video games I did yeah
that led you getting this amazing movie
role right well in a very lucky
ended way ya know this show made me a
particular agoraphobic you know I would
I wouldn't move down the street I would
have a hat on the thing up and I would
just never look anybody in the eye it
really kind of made me afraid to to see
people and look at me there is an ugly
side to Fame such as it is yeah I didn't
really appeal to me and that was when I
did find World of Warcraft and started
playing world of work I did I did I mean
18 hours a day just sat there in my
pants ordering Chinese food and using
coke cans from the last week as ashtrays
it was really a glamorous I didn't think
I were gonna say
I go to the bathroom or there's this
Coke yeah well the bathroom was
sometimes yeah it was the late there was
a there was a particular thing where
this game suddenly became my life and
this game would slowly give me rewards
and it allowed me to talk to people and
make friends on there who were judging
me anonymously not know but for the
contact what they saw you do on TV is
that had any yes exactly so I was able
to like forge new relationships that
didn't come with any preconceptions and
I was slowly given these rewards in game
that Believe It or Not affected my
confidence gave me the boost and and
before you know it I was able to have a
little bit of self belief again and you
know I credit World of Warcraft we're
saving my life but the problem is once
I'd reached that point it was the two
years after that where I just kind of
got fat and I did I'd kept kept on
playing and I'd put on about 50 pounds
and I was just happy I was literally
just bellied out like that character
it's nice you can put the controller
right on the back that's what I like
exactly like this it was it was you know
I have a really wonderful life now I
have I have the perfect girlfriend I
have I I'm doing a great movie that I
love have a great TV show I'm living in
in Los Angeles it's pretty great but
I've never been happier than when I was
really fat and no one had any
expectations of me and I was playing
video game make sure you tell your
girlfriend that you can see right there
she's on a boat leaving you playa orgrim
Doomhammer in in the Warcraft movie and
we have a picture of you in the
character here and my god yeah you did
put on weight that is actually not me
that's a model of me ah there I think do
you have the other shot I think we have
another shot of you or maybe that's me
that's you very different yeah right
yeah no unfortunately I did put on about
that much weight but it didn't matter
cuz the whole thing was motion capture
right so they do a lot of if there's
some CGI says it's all CGI okay it was
one of the best experience of my life we
have to wrap this up because of time but
before we go how would you go at me as a
fighter now
look at this and you see I have the
reach you do have every reach I have a
head that bobs around mocking you but
what would be your approach this face
just looming like my main fear is you
probably have the largest head I've ever
seen on it but it would either come in
like that it would either have a certain
gravitational field so I just it would
just break a finger on it yeah
intimidating Prem I can tell you fear me
physically and that's really all I
wanted to get out of this interview